SHAAN: Welcome, everybody.
My name is Shaan.
DAKE: Hi, my name's Dake.
KEYVAN: Hi, my name's Keyvan.
SHAAN: We're engineers
in the Android TV Team,
and we all work in
the Leanback Library.
Just a few years back,
development on TV
was considered
difficult, exclusively
available to TV manufacturers.
But times have
changed now, and TVs
are starting to evolve at
the hands of developers.
What was considered a black box
running some archaic software
is now running our
familiar Android OS.
If you know how to
build apps for Android,
you're already ready
to build apps for TV.
Leanback is the
recommended library
for building apps on
TV, and today we'll
show you how you can
Leanback Library to build
some amazing experiences on TV.
When building apps
for TV, you have
to keep in mind
users are already
used to interacting
with TV for a long time.
The central guiding principle
when building apps for TV
is to strike a balance between
consistency and flexibility.
That is, we want to
empower the developer
to build unique experiences
while at the same time
maintain consistency
across apps,
thereby eliminate the need for
users to learn to use new apps.
And if you think about
it, Android phones and TVs
are not that different.
They both part of
the same Android OS.
But there are two
key differences
that you should keep in
mind when building apps.
One, TVs don't
support touchscreen.
And second, users
are usually seated
a few feet behind the TV.
As such, the navigation model
for TV is quite different.
Usually you can go
top, down, left,
right from any given point.
In the next 45
minutes, we'll walk you
through different components
that come with the Leanback
Library, the features that we
have added to those components,
and some of the other
underutilized features
of existing components.
Now, Leanback provides the
basic building blocks for UI.
It comes with support for Cards,
Rows, List of Rows, Actions,
Grids, Fragments.
Using these basic
building blocks,
you can build complex
UI hierarchies.
But not just basic
building blocks,
it also makes heavy
use of transition
to guide the user
through your flow.
Now, no matter what
app you are building,
you'd want to display content
in a way that's intuitive
and easily accessible.
Leanback's answer to
this is BrowseFragment.
It displays content
in a set of rows.
It consists of three things.
It has the HeadersFragment
to the left,
which has the navigation menu
arranged in a vertical list.
It has the title bar to the top,
which displays your branding
information in a row.
And then it has the RowsFragment
to the right, which displays
your content in a set of rows.
Now, BrowseFragment does a
lot of heavy lifting for you.
It runs a transition,
it takes care
of the coordination
between the HeadersFragment
and the RowsFragment,
it also shows and hides
the TitleView at
appropriate times.
It is very comprehensive.
With just a few lines of code,
you can get up and running.
But you don't want to
build a generic app.
You want to build
something that is unique,
something that has character,
something that people
can spot from a distance.
Next, we'll walk you through
different techniques you can
employ to make your app unique.
But before, this is an
example implementation
of BrowseFragment.
As you can see, with
just a few lines of code,
you have a functional app.
All you have to do is set
the branding information
with a setBadgeDurable call.
Then you load the data
and populate the data
and set the data in the code by
calling the setAdapter method.
And finally, you
set your listeners.
That's all you need to do in
order to have a functional app.
One caveat you want
to keep in mind
is if you want to run
the EntranceTransition,
you want to call it the first
time you go into your app.
And we'll talk about this
in a little more detail
in a later slide.
Remember I mentioned
HeadersFragment
appears to the left, has the
list of navigation menus?
Now, that is great, but
what if you wanted to group
your navigation menus?
For this, the latest
version of Leanback Library
has support for two new rows,
SectionRow and DividerRow.
SectionRow, which is the
title, marks the beginning
of a group of navigation menus.
And DividerRow marks
the ending of the group.
The way to add them is as simple
as when you're adding data
to your adapter,
you're going to inject
those rows in the same order
that you want them to appear
in the HeadersFragment.
That's it.
Now, HeadersFragment is
an optional component.
You can either enable
it or disable it.
And by doing so, your app will
have a very different look
and feel to it.
The way to do that is by
calling setHeadersState function
with either HeadersState
enabled or disabled parameter.
Leanback, in an effort to
separate styling from logic,
makes heavy use of
Android theming.
Every component in Leanback
comes with its own theme.
Now, if you want to customize
a component, all you have to do
is create a style that
extends from the theme
and override the attributes
that you care about.
Here is an example
of a BrowseFragment.
It doesn't even look like
a classical BrowseFragment.
Here we have offset the content
to the bottom of the page
by using a combination of
MarginTop and PaddingStart.
You see, the power of
theme is, without changing
a single line of code, just
by overriding two attributes,
you can give a different
look and feel to your app.
Leanback comes with an extensive
set of Styles and Themes.
We encourage you to take a
look at the Style [INAUDIBLE]
for Leanback and see what makes
sense for you to override.
The TitleView, which appears
on the top of BrowseFragment
is where you just put
your branding information.
The classical TitleView
displays a search icon, a title,
or a logo.
Now, that is great,
but what if you
want to display your
own custom view?
The latest version of Leanback
supports Custom TitleView.
The first thing you want to
do is create a custom view.
Second, you want to create
a tight layout file which
uses your custom view.
And then you're going to
override the Browse [INAUDIBLE]
view layout property with the
location of your layout file.
As soon as you do that,
BrowseFragment will pick up
the layout you
created and render
that in the top section
of BrowseFragment.
As a final step,
though, you will
have to implement the TitleView
adapter provider interface.
The TitleView
adapter interface is
what BrowseFragment uses to
communicate with your fragment.
It's used to tell your view
to show or hide itself.
Leanback comes with a default
implementation of TitleView,
which implements the
TitleView adapter.
We encourage you to take
a look at the source code
and see how that's implemented.
We talk to a lot of
developers-- TV app developers--
and there was a growing
consensus about the need
for further customization.
Now, BrowseFragment is great.
It displays item
in a set of rows.
But what if you wanted to
do something more custom?
Maybe you have a fragment
for your phone app
that you want to
repurpose for your TV app.
Or maybe you want to have
a completely different
representation of
your media items.
For these use
cases, we introduced
what's called PageRow,
which is a subclass of Row.
With PageRow, you can
have your custom fragment
rendered inside BrowseFragment.
Typically, developers will pair
the header item which ListRow,
which represents a
collection of items.
Now, BrowseFragment
internally maintains
a registry which
maps each Row type
to a corresponding factory.
In this specific case,
we mapped the ListRow
to RowsFragment, which
knows how to render
each individual item in a set
of cards in a horizontal grid.
For PageRows, you want to pair
each header item with a Page
Row, and then register your
factory with BrowseFragment.
Then as soon as
BrowseFragment sees a PageRow,
it's going to look
into its registry,
find out your factory, and
then using the factory,
it's going to
instantiate your fragment
and then render that in
the main content area.
With that being said,
we will jump into a demo
and see this in action.
KEYVAN: Thank you, Shaan.
So here I will demo a
new sample app which
we developed for Android TV.
We just open sourced
this app yesterday,
and the URL to GitHub
will be provided
at the end of this presentation.
But for demo purposes here,
we are using the Android TV
Emulator.
So the home screen of this
app is a BrowseFragment
which consists of a
set of different Cards.
Each Card here represents
a separate component
within Leanback.
I will start off this demo
by showing different examples
of custom fragments.
This BrowseFragment consists
of four different custom
fragments.
When I switch within the
rows, a different fragment
will be loaded each time.
The first fragment displays
images in a vertical grid.
Here, for example, I
can navigate images
across different rows.
The next row is an example
of a standard RowsFragment
that is embedded within
a custom fragment.
Here you'll see
several icons that are
organized into multiple rows.
The next example shows
the setting icons
embedded within two rows.
And finally, we have an example
where a WebView is embedded
within a custom fragment.
Unfortunately, the
Wi-Fi connectivity
is not very great here, so
the part that requires network
will not play.
But just in case,
you know, there's
going to be a full cool
page displayed on the right.
So this example showed that we
can embed any custom fragments
inside a BrowseFragment.
You might have also noticed that
we have a TitleView on the top.
We can embed any
custom widget in here.
For example, here we are
using a custom layout
with a text view
and an analog clock.
Thanks.
SHAAN: Thanks, Keyvan.
So the demo Gods are
not in favor of us.
Trust me, the web page will
load if you embed the WebView
inside the CustomFragment.
Anyway, so we talked
about CustomFragment.
Now we'll show you how you
can wire your CustomFragment
inside BrowseFragment,
and then we'll
show you some snippets of code.
Remember, I mentioned
BrowseFragment
has an internal registry
which maps each row type
to a corresponding factory.
Now, when you supply
a page row, it's
going to look into the registry,
find the factory corresponding
to the page row,
and use that factory
to instantiate your fragment.
Now, your fragment
must implement
MainFragmentAdapterProvider.
This is the interface
that BrowseFragment
uses to get a hold of
MainFragmentAdapter.
Now, you may ask,
what is that adapter?
Well, MainFragmentAdapter
is the interface
that BrowseFragment uses to
communicate with your fragment.
For events such as, like,
I'm starting the animation
or I'm running animation
or the animation is over.
Things like that.
Now, there is another
optional component
called MainFragmentRowsAdapter.
This is a special case that
is only used by RowsFragment.
This is used by BrowseFragment
to communicate row-based events
so that it can sync
both the HeadersFragment
and RowsFragment.
Now, RowsFragment comes
with the implementation
for this adapter.
We'll encourage you to take
a look at the source code
and see how that's implemented.
Now, these are all different
ways BrowseFragment
can talk to your fragment.
But what if your fragment wanted
to talk to BrowseFragment?
For that we provide
FragmentHost,
which represents
all possible actions
that your fragment is allowed
to take on BrowseFragment.
Now let's take a
look at some code.
The first thing you
want to do if you
want to implement CustomFragment
is implement FragmentFactory.
All you have to do is override
one method, CreateFragment.
Now remember, the data that's
passed into CreateFragment
is the currently selected
row, which is either a page
row or a subclass of page row.
So you can type
[INAUDIBLE] to a page row
and then inspect
the data in there
and return the appropriate
instance of the fragment.
Once you do that, then you
want to register your factory
with BrowseFragment.
And we recommend you do that in
the constructor of your class.
Next you want to implement the
MainFragmentAdapterProvider
to return an instance
of MainFragmentAdapter.
This is the interface
that BrowseFragment
uses to communicate
with your fragment.
As a final step, you
have to implement
the MainFragmentAdapter.
Now, BrowseFragment comes
with a default implementation
of MainFragmentAdapter, but if
that doesn't satisfy your need,
you can extend from it
and override the behavior
that you care about.
The general pattern
for implementing
this is the adapter should
act like a passthrough
to your fragment.
Here, we override the
setEntranceTransitionState
method and then callback
into the fragment.
The fragment in turn,
based on the Boolean value,
sets the visibility of
the individual views.
So the transition system
can notice the difference
and run the
appropriate transition.
It's as simple as that.
So that's a lot
about CustomFragment.
Now let's talk about Cards.
Cards are another key
component of Leanback Library.
One of the key classes
that comes with Leanback
is called ImageCardView.
That's used to render cards.
It consists of two areas.
There is the Image Area which
displays your image on top,
and there's the Info
Area at the bottom which
displays your content.
It say Title and Description
and an optional icon.
Now, whatever app you're
building, if you're displaying
audio, video, or whatever
media you want to display,
it'll be displayed in Cards.
But just because you are
rendering everything in Cards
doesn't mean all your Cards
will have to look alike.
You can have different types of
Cards in the same application.
And the way to do
that is by creating
a style that extends
from ImageCardView style
and overriding the attribute
that you care about.
One such interesting attribute
is the lbImageCardViewType.
This controls what content
gets rendered in the Card.
It takes four possible values,
Title, Content, Icon Right,
and Icon Left, and these
are not mutually exclusive.
Here are three Cards with
three different values
for this attribute.
The one on the left displays
the Title in the Info Area.
The one in the middle displays
Title and the Content.
And the one on the very right
displays Title, Content,
and the Icon on the Left.
You can see just by
creating new styles
you can have different
representation for your Cards.
Another interesting
attribute is cardType.
This controls the positioning
of Info Area in relation
to your Image Area.
It has three possible
values, infoUnder, infoOver,
and mainOnly.
And here are three cards which
use the three different values
for this attribute.
The first one, this is
a default configuration.
It displays the Info Area
underneath the Image View.
The second one, infoOver,
lines up the Info Area
with the bottom
of the Image Card.
So Info Area appears to
be on top of the card.
And the final one, mainOnly,
hides the Info Area altogether.
In this case, you
are free to supply
any custom layout you want.
In this specific
case, we are using
a custom layout which
displays the Content
to the right of the image.
Now, once you create
your style, there
are two more steps you
need to do in order
to create Custom Cards.
First, you're going
to create a theme
and override the
ImageCardViewStyle
attribute with the
style you just created.
You can choose to override
other attributes if you want to.
Once you do that, then you can
instantiate your ImageCardView
and use the theme
you just created
using ContextThemeWrapper.
That's it.
That's all you need to do in
order to create Custom Cards.
Now, there are other attributes
that you can override,
you can play around with and
see if that kind of gives you
a little more control over the
look and feel of the Cards.
We'll encourage you to take
a look at the Style Files
and see what makes sense
for you to override.
Now, just in case ImageCardView
doesn't satisfy your need,
you can also look
at BaseCardView,
which is the base
class for ImageCardView
and gives you control
over both the layout
as well as the content that
is rendered on the Card.
With that being said, we'll
jump into a quick demo
and show you different
kinds of Cards.
KEYVAN: Next I'm going to demo
different types of Cards here.
This BrowseFragment
shows several variations
of ImageCardView
and BaseCardView.
In the first row, we
have ImageCardView where
the Title spans a single line.
Here we see some
examples of this Card.
The second row
displays ImageCardView,
but the Title spans two
lines, and the Rating Icon
is to the left.
The next one is an example
of ImageCardView where
all the components are present.
We have the ImageView on
top, the Title, the Rating
Icon to the left, and the
Content, which is the price,
here to the right.
We have more variations
of ImageCardViews
in the next couple of rows.
But if these ImageCardViews
don't satisfy your needs
and you need to have more
control over the card
appearance, here are
some advanced examples.
In this row we have
examples of BaseCardView
with the mainOnly card type.
This one uses a custom layout
with the content placed
to the right of the image.
The next row is another
example of BaseCardView
with a mainOnly card type.
Here, however, instead
of the image on the top,
you are using a Text View.
We have more variations of
ImageCardView in the next row.
And finally, we
have ImageCardView
where we have provided
onFocusChange listener.
You'll notice that
the background changes
as a card receives focus.
Thank you.
SHAAN: Thanks, Keyvan.
So we talked a lot
about BrowseFragment
and CustomFragment and Cards.
Next, Dake is going
to talk about the best
practices for
Entrance Transition
and I'll also talk about
some of the other components
in Leanback.
DAKE: Thank you, Shaan.
Animations.
So BrowseFragment is usually
inside the first activity
of your app, which might
take a while to load data.
So the user will
see a blank screen
when data is being loaded.
If your app loads
data row-by-row,
item-by-item, the user might
see multiple screen updates
during data being loaded.
To solve these
problems, BrowseFragment
has a best practice called
Entrance Transition.
This is one of the less known
feature of Leanback Library
I'm going to talk about today.
Entrance Transition gives
user a visual feedback
that the data is being loaded.
As you can see, there's
a spinning icon there.
Once the data finish
loading, BrowseFragment
will slide content
from two sides.
Next, Keyvan's
going to do a demo.
SHAAN: Thank you, Dake.
KEYVAN: So before we go into
the details of the Entrance
Transition, here I will showcase
an example Entrance Transition
in Leanback.
I will play the
BrowseFragment here.
You'll notice that we have a
slide-in transition happening
from the opposite sides.
The HeadersFragment is
sliding from the left,
and the RowsFragment is
sliding from the right.
To capture this
transition once more,
I will play this
demo once again.
And here is how it looks.
BrowseFragment not only
supports Entrance Transition
for RowsFragment, but any
Custom Fragments can also
take advantage of that.
For instance, here when I
open on any Custom Fragment,
you'll notice that once the
data loading is complete,
you'll have similar
Entrance Transition.
The RowsFragment is
sliding from the left,
and the Custom Fragment
is sliding from the right.
I will play this once more.
And with that, Dake
will cover the details
of Entrance Transitions.
DAKE: So let's take
a look how your app
can use Entrance Transition.
This is a two-steps process.
First, you app call
prepareEntranceTransition
in your fragment onCreate.
This tells BrowseFragment
don't show anything yet
until I tell you to do so later.
Internally, BrowseFragment will
hide the content on the left
and hide all the views
inside the main area.
The next step, once your
app loads all your data,
you call this
startEntranceTransition.
This is a signal
tells BrowseFragment
that all my data is ready.
Now you can start the animation.
If you are just using
classical BrowseFragment
displaying a list of rows,
all you need to do now
is prepareEntranceTransition and
startEntranceTransition calls.
But what if your app has
your own Custom Fragment?
To make your Custom Fragment
part of the Entrance
Transition, you need to
implement this method
inside the MainFragmentAdapter.
When BrowseFragment prepare
Entrance Transition,
it calls into this
method telling
you to hide all
the IndividualViews
inside your Custom Fragment.
When BrowseFragment
start the animation,
it will tell you to
show all IndividualViews
through the same method with
a different Parameter Value.
Now, we also have
these three callbacks.
These are optional because
RowsFragment internally
uses RecyclerView.
You might know that RecyclerView
animation cannot be run
together with
Transition Animations,
so the RowsFragment
listen to this callbacks,
it disabled animation in
our transition prepare,
it disabled the layout
when transition started,
and it re-enabled layout and
re-enabled animation when
transition finishes.
Remember, these are optional.
Only if your Custom Fragment
is also using RecyclerView
you need to listen
to these callbacks.
Now, because BrowseFragment
needs to hide and show
views inside your fragment,
so your Custom Fragment needs
to let BrowseFragment know
your view has been created.
You are doing so by
calling notifyViewCreated
on the fragment host object.
And also, because your
Custom Fragment usually
has your own data, which
can take extra time to load,
this data is not the same
data inside the BrowseFragment
Adapter.
So remember, you need to
call startEntranceTransition
to tell BrowseFragment that
all the data inside the Browse
Adapter is ready.
So here, your Custom
Fragment needs
to call additional
method notifyDataReady
to tell BrowseFragment that
the data inside your Custom
Fragment is ready.
And then BrowseFragment
can do the transitions.
So to put all the
pieces together
we have this sequence diagram.
First, your app calls
prepareEntranceTransition
in onCreate.
Then BrowseFragment will
hide all the HeaderViews
and don't show anything
in the main area.
Then BrowseFragment
starts loading data.
Once it loads the PageRow,
it will create your fragment
from the factory.
Next, once all the data inside
the BrowseFragment is loaded,
it calls
startEntranceTransition.
But we cannot start animation
yet because your fragment is
not ready.
So BrowseFragment is
waiting for your fragment
to call notifyViewCreated.
So then BrowseFragment
calls setEntranceTrans
itionState(false).
This tells your Custom
Fragment to hide all the views
inside your fragment.
At the last step, once your
fragment load all data,
you call notifyDataReady.
And then BrowseFragment
calls setEntranceTrans
itionState(true), which tells
you to show all the views.
Then we can start animation.
So we have talked a lot
about BrowseFragment today.
In the next section,
I'm going to talk
about some other fragments
in Leanback Libraries.
If your app wants to
interact with user on TV,
we recommend you to use
this GuidedStepFragment.
This is a UX designed
for a user sitting
10 feet away from the TV.
So the screen is very
simple, as you can see.
To the left, we call
it Guidance Area.
This is the read-only area
that prompts user what
user can do on this screen.
To the right is a list
of Guided Actions.
This is the area that
user can interact with.
Next Keyvan's going
to do a quick demo.
KEYVAN: So say you
want to rent a movie.
Here I will show you an
example workflow of doing so
using GuidedStepFragment.
GuidedStepFragment
here presents the user
with a sequence of fragments.
At each step, it'll ask the
user to take a set of actions.
It will also make
it easy for the user
to navigate back and forth
across all the fragments.
So I will start off by
choosing the Rent HD
version of the movie here.
But let's say at this
point I change my mind
and I want to rent the SD
version of the movie instead.
I can easily navigate back
to the previous screen
and select the SD version
of the movie here.
Here we see an example
of a GuidedStepFragment
with a drop-down action.
I can either choose one of
the existing credit cards
where I have entered
before, or if I want,
I can add a new credit card
in a new fragment screen.
Here we see an example of an
editable action where I can
enter my credit card number.
So I will go ahead and enter
my real credit card number.
And once I'm done
with that, I'm going
to pick a valid expiration date.
This is an example
of a date picker
widget provided by Leanback.
You'll notice that once
the information I entered
about my credit
card is validated,
the OK button is enabled.
Next I will hit the
OK button, and I
will be directed back to
the previous screen where
I left off.
Next I will choose the Rent.
And after the
processing is complete,
I will be presented
with a final screen
where I can start
watching the movie,
You'll see that once
I selected Watch Now,
GuidedStepFragment will close
all the existing fragments
and a new video
will start playing.
Unfortunately, again, the
video will not play here,
but believe it, it's going
to be a really nice video.
And with that, Dake
will cover the details
of GuidedStepFragment.
DAKE: Thank you, Keyvan.
So to create your
GuidedStepFragment,
you extend from the Base
Class GuidedStepFragment
and override these
three methods.
First, you provide
Guidance, which is
the read-only area to the left.
Second, you provide a list of
Guided Actions for the user.
And then you respond
to user actions
and do something for your app.
A Guided Action,
it has an id, which
is identified for
your program to know
which Guided Action the
user has interacted with.
It has a Title and Description.
So the basic Guided Action
is a click-only action.
You can also make
a Guided Action
like a radio or a check box.
You can make the
Title editable, or you
can make the Description
editable, but not
both at the same time.
Here are some advanced
examples, the DatePicker
and a list of SubActions which
implement the drop-down list
feature.
To use the GuidedStepFragment,
you have two choices.
You either start the workflow
in a separate activity
or you can start the flow
in your existing activity.
In the first approach, you call
addAsRoot in activity onCreate.
Remember, you only do this
with certain instances now.
If your activity is restoring
from certain instance,
the Fragment Manager
will automatically
restore the fragment
for you so you
don't add a duplicate
fragment in this case.
If your app don't
want to use Activity,
if you want to do everything
in fragments, that's fine.
You can add the Guided Step on
top of your existing content.
To navigate between
the fragments,
you usually do this by
responding to user actions
and callAddFunction with
the new fragment name
that you want to navigate to.
The fragments are added
using BackStack entry.
So if user click Back
button on the remote,
he will be taken back
to the previous screen.
But sometimes your app wants
to go multiple step back.
You can call this popBackStep
which is a specific Class
Name of the fragment.
Finally, if you want
to finish your flow,
you call
finishGuidedStepFragment.
This will close all the
GuidedStepFragments.
And, if your flow was started
in a separate activity,
it will also close the activity.
Settings.
So in Android N, we have
redesigned the Android TV
Settings app.
It's now like a set panel
laying on top of other content.
If you want your app also
to use the same feature,
you can use
LeanbackSettingsFragment.
This fragment starts
with a HeaderView
followed by a list of
Preference Objects.
Each Preference Object has
Icon, Title, a Summary.
Optionally, the
Preference Object
has embedded widget inside it.
In this case, it's
a switch widget.
So I'm not going into the
details of SettingsFragment,
but you are welcome to
take a look at the sample
code in a Showcase app.
PlaybackOverlayFragment.
When your app tried to
play audio or, like I say,
podcast, then you might use
PlaybackOverlayControlFragment.
This fragment usually starts
with a PlaybackControlsRow.
With the upcoming release,
we provided support for you
to render in a Media Item Row.
A Media Item Row has two parts.
To the left is the
Media Item Details.
It includes the Track Number,
the Song Title, and Duration.
To the right, there are
multiple clickable actions.
To use this feature,
your app extends
from AbstractMediaItemPresenter,
which
is responsible for
rendering a row.
You override onBindMediaDetails.
Your Media Item
can be any class.
It doesn't need to be a
subclass of a Row Object.
So you get the values
from your song object
and then fill that data
into the ViewHolder.
Optionally, if you want
to support the actions
to the right of the
MediaItemDetails,
you can implement this
provider interface
and provide a list of actions.
KEYVAN: Next I'm going to demo
the PlaybackOverlyFragment.
This fragment comes with
a set of new features
which will be available in the
upcoming Android N release.
Once I open this fragment,
the first song will start.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I will pause the song right now.
So the top section
of this fragment
is the Playback Media Player,
and the button section
is the Media Item Rows.
All the individual components
within this fragment
can be customized through
Themes and Styling.
For instance, the
developers can specify
the information about the
currently playing song;
the primary set of actions,
such as Play or Pause;
the secondary set of actions,
such as Thumbs Up or Thumbs
Down; and on the bottom we
have the Media Item Rows.
Each Media Item Row can
consist of information
such as the Title of the song,
the Duration, the Artist.
And they are followed with
a set of optional actions.
For the actions
here we are having
the Add to the Playlist button
and the Favorite button action.
In Leanback, we
provide listener hooks
for either selecting
or clicking on each one
of these individual components.
So let's say I want
to listen to a song.
I can do that by clicking
on the Media Item
Details for that song--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
--and that will start
playing the song.
And say at some point into
the song, I really enjoy this
and I want to
favorite that song.
I can easily navigate back
to the song that's playing
and hit the Favorite
button here.
That will highlight that
row a different color,
which will make it easy
for me to later find
my Favorite List of Songs.
And that concludes
our demonstration,
and I'd like to hand
it over to Shaan.
SHAAN: So we've covered
a lot of ground today.
First, we talked about how
easy it is for you to get up
and running with just
a few lines of code
using BrowseFragment.
Then we showed you
different techniques
you can employ to give
your app some character.
Let me show you how you
can plug-in your Custom
Fragment inside BrowseFragment.
We showed you how to use
different kinds of Cards
in the same application.
We talked about
the best practices
for running Entrance Transition.
We also showed you how you
can use GuidedStepFragment
to walk a user to a workflow.
We showed you the newly styled
SettingsFragment and the newly
redesigned PlaybackFragment.
Hopefully you got a
sense how Leanback
tries to provide a
comprehensive set of components
for supporting different
use cases on TV.
That being said, we are
always interested in listening
to developer comments, feedback,
suggestions, feature requests.
We can't wait to see what
you're going to build
with the new Leanback Library.
Thank you very much for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
Before we go into Q&A, a couple
things I want to call out.
Our Sandbox TV is right
around the corner,
so please come by, say
hello, and see this in action
if you want to.
And the second is if you
guys are watching remotely,
then we have a developer
community on Google+.
Please join the community and
we'll be sharing helpful tips
and also helping you solve
any problems that you
run into there.
And we have the
Showcase app, which
is available on
GitHub for cloning.
Please play around with it.
If you have any questions,
suggestions, let us know.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
I have a question
about the WebView.
In the beginning you
showed that you now
plug in the WebView, right?
But as I remember
the guidelines,
you said to avoid
using the WebView
because TV is not for web.
So is something
changing here or?
SHAAN: I think you
are absolutely right.
We don't recommend
using WebView.
There was an example
aimed to display
the flexibility of
Custom Fragment, what
you can do with it.
But you're absolutely
right, we shouldn't be
using WebView inside TV apps.
Any other questions?
Yeah, we'll be around
in the Sandbox area.
Please come by and--
[MUSIC PLAYING]